WE WIRE GUYS ON THE COURT
JUST TO HEAR
WHAT'S GOING ON
BEHIND THE SCENES.
SO CHECK IT OUT.
- ARE WE DOING INTRODUCTIONS?
- ALL RIGHT.
- JEFF. NICE TO SEE YOU.
JEFF. ALL RIGHT?
I LIKE THAT.
HERE WE GO.
GET BACK ON DEFENSE.
[blowing whistle]
THAT'S A CHARGE.
YOU SEEN
BIG MOMMA'S HOUSE?
I THOUGHT THAT MOVIE
WAS FUNNY.
WHAT ARE YOU GUYS GETTING UP TO
AFTER THE GAME TONIGHT?
YOU KNOW, YOU GOING
TO RED ROBIN?
WHAT ARE YOU GUYS
GONNA DO?
IS THERE A LIST, OR IS THIS,
UH, ANYBODY CAN WALK UP?
IS IT ONE OF THOSE LIST--
LIST THINGS?
I'M BEHIND YOU,
I'M BEHIND YOU.
ONE, TWO, THREE,
DRINKS ON THE COACH.
[laughing]
YOU GUYS GOT PLANS TONIGHT?
I'M, UH...
PROBABLY HANGING OUT
WITH THE PLAYERS.
IT'S A LIST-ONLY THING CLUB
SO YOU...
YOU PIECES OF [bleep]
CAN'T COME. LET'S GO!
44.
THAT'S A FOUL
ON 44.
LOOK, IF YOU GUYS
WANT TO HANG OUT LATER,
WE CAN'T ARGUE LIKE THIS,
ALL RIGHT?
I HAVEN'T LOCKED IN PLANS YET,
- THESE GUYS ARE NOT
YOUR FRIENDS.
WE'RE NOT GOING OUT
FOR DRINKS.
- FORGET ABOUT YOU.
YOU GOT PLANS TONIGHT?
- YEAH.
- YEAH?
NO, YEAH, THOSE GUYS
WANT TO TAKE ME OUT,
BUT I HAVEN'T LOCKED
ANYTHING IN YET, SO...
LET ME KNOW.
ALL RIGHT.
I DIDN'T HAVE A DAD.
THAT'S WHAT I GOT IN COMMON
WITH YOU BLACK KIDS.
WHAT ARE YOU GUYS UP TO TONIGHT?
YOU GOT ANY PLANS?
- [grunting]
- [blowing whistle]
THAT'S A FOUL.
LITTLE HELP.
I WANT ONE OF THE PLAYERS
TO DO IT.
[groaning]
[sobs]
STOP CRYING,
YOU LITTLE BITCH.
THAT'S WHY DAD WALKED OUT.
THAT'S WHY EVERYBODY LEAVES.
[clearing throat]
- YOU KNOW, SOMETIMES
WHAT YOU HEAR ON THE COURT
WILL MAKE YOU
STRAIGHT-UP SAD.
WE'LL BE BACK.